we're told that polygon q is a scaled
copy of polygon p
using a scale factor of one half
polygon q's area is what fraction of
polygon p's area
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right my brain wants to make this a
little bit tangible and once we get some
practice you might be able to do it
without drawing pictures but they're
saying some arbitrary polygon q and p so
let's just make a simple one since we're
talking about area i like to deal with
rectangles since it's easy to think
about areas of rectangles and so let's
see polygon q is a scaled copy of
polygon p so let's start with polygon p
and i will do this in red
so polygon p
let's just say
i'm just going to create an arbitrary
polygon
so let's say that this is and i'm going
to scale it by one half so i'm going to
make it sides have nice even numbers so
let's say this side right over here is 4
and this side right over here is equal
to 8. this is polygon p right over here
it's a quadrilateral it's in fact a
rectangle and its area
area
is just going to be 4 times 8 which is
32.
now let's create polygon q and remember
polygon q is a scaled copy of p using a
scale factor of one half so we're going
to scale it by one half
so instead of this side being 4 it's
going to be 2.
instead of this side over here this
being 8 the corresponding side in the
scaled version is going to be 4.
so there you go we've scaled it by
one-half and now what is our area going
to be
well our area and this is polygon q
and so our area is going to be 2 times 4
which is equal to 8.
so notice the polygon q's area is
one-fourth of polygon p's area and that
makes sense because when you scale the
dimensions of the polygon by one-half
the area is going to change by the
square of that one-half squared is
one-fourth and so the area has been
changed by a factor of one-fourth or
another way to answer this question
polygon q's area is what fraction of
polygon p's area well it's going to be
one-fourth
of polygon p's area and the big takeaway
here is if you scale something if you
scale the sides of a figure by one half
each then the area is going to be the
square of that and so one half squared
is
over 4. if it was scaled by 1 3 then the
area would be scaled or the area would
be 1 9. if it was if you scaled by a
factor of 2 then our area would have
grown by a factor of 4. let's do another
example
here we are told rectangle n has an area
of 5 square units let me do this in a
different color so rectangle
n has an area of five square units
james drew a scaled version of rectangle
n and labeled it rectangle p so they
have that right over here this is a
scaled version of rectangle n what scale
factor did james use to go from
rectangle n to rectangle p
so let's think about it we give us
rectangle p
right over here and let's think about
its dimensions this height is one two
three four five it's five high
and it is one two three four five six
seven eight nine wide and so its area
its area is equal to
45.
now rectangle
rectangle
n had an area of 5 square units so our
area let me write this down so
n
area
to
p area
and area to p area we are multiplying by
a factor of nine for going from an area
of five square units to 45 square units
notice n area is 5.
in that color
n's area is 5 square units p's area we
just figured out is 45 square units and
so
we have it growing by a factor of 9.
now what would be the scale factor if
our area grew by a factor of 9
well we just talked about the idea that
area will grow the factor with which
area grows is the square of the scale
factor so one way to think about it is
scale factor
scale
factor
squared is going to be equal to nine
or another way to think about it our
scale factor scale
factor is going to be equal to
3 to go from n to p now let's verify
that that we answered their question but
i just wanted us to feel good about it
let's draw a rectangle that is scaled
down from p by a factor of three
so or a rectangle if we were to scale it
up by a factor of three we get rectangle
p
so its bottom would have length three
instead of nine
so it'd be like this so that would be
three
and its height instead of being five it
would be five thirds five thirds is one
and two thirds so it'd go about that
high it would look something like that
it would be five thirds
and so
our rectangle n
would look like this and what is its
area well 5 thirds times 3 is indeed 5
square units so notice when we have the
area growing by a factor of nine the
scale factor of the size to go from five
thirds to five you multiply by three to
go from three to nine you multiply by
three